bonjour monsieur colombiès merci d'être
en direct avec nous un nouveau drame
dans la police neuvième suicide en moins
d'un mois comment expliquez-vous ce
profond mal être au sein des forces de
l'ordre
bonjour tout d'abord sur ce tableau y
aurait plusieurs coups de gueule à
passer on va essayer de se limiter dans
cette démarche
l'histoire se met l'histoire bégaye et
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
seulement cette année que la
problématique des suicides existe il
existe depuis très longtemps depuis trop
longtemps
l'association que je représente n'a eu
de cesse de dénoncer ce phénomène qui
s'inscrit dans un dans une dans un
contexte très globale y aurait si vous
le permettez de deux niveaux d'analysé à
faire pour bien comprendre ce qui est en
train de se passer plutôt ce qui se
passe depuis des années il ya eu une
analyse à maquereau qu'on pourrait
qualifier de maquereau qui consiste à
envisager la problématique de la police
au sein de la société quelle est sa
place question les difficultés qu'elles
rencontrent pour exercer ses missions
pour ne pas dire son impossibilité à
remplir ses missions vous comprendrez
bien que moi je suis pas du tout un
porte parole du gouvernement est de
quelque gouvernement que ce soit cela
fait des années cela fait plus de vingt
ans que la police subi une succession de
politique sécuritaire
les plus incohérentes les unes par
rapport aux autres nous avons eu une
droit une pol prox qui ne tenait compte
d'aucune réalité du terrain ensuite nous
avons une forme de délire chiffrés qui
s'est traduit par la politique du
chiffre edit du résultat est dit pardon
du résultat même si auparavant avant
avant cette allemagne avait pas de
résultats nous avons eu droit aux aides
et speed et manuel valls et maintenant
nous avons droit au quartier de
répliques de reconquête républicaine du
gouvernement macro nist tout ça deux
concours à une forme de désorientation
complète des missions de police que dans
dans le cadre desquelles les postiers ne
se reconnaissent pas les policiers sont
des citoyens comme les autres nous
évoluions ils évoluent dans au sein
d'une société qui vous avez bien compris
ils feront de ça on n'a de cesse de le
dire une société qui est en crise
profondément fracturé et il n'est pas
surprenant que ce mal-être
connaissent une répercussion des mines
liés au sein de l'institution qui est
malmené
il ya actuellement des
dispositifs de prévention qui existent
gérald darmanin qui a annoncé aussi le
recrutement de plusieurs psychologues
pour venir en aide justement à ces
policiers à ce mal être on sent bien que
le phénomène peine à être endiguée voulu
vous le disiez 1 c'est un phénomène qui
n'est pas récente qu'est ce qui se passe
à ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement là la
hiérarchie le ministère de l'intérieur
est complètement déconnecté de la
réalité ou finalement ces mesures ne
sont efficaces non quand vous dites que
le ministère donateurs est complètement
déconnecté de la réalité vous est encore
loin du problème il est plus que
déconnecté il ne tient aucun compte des
réalités nommé nommé une vingtaine de
psychologues pour les envoyer au contact
des services de police c'est comme si
vous nommiez 26 infirmières pour aller
sur le front de garda en face à manny
queue ni tête surtout que monsieur
darmanin et quand même mal placé pour
tenter d'endiguer un problème auquel il
a lui-même participé lorsqu'il était un
proche un disciple de nicolas sarkozy et
qui donc qu'il sait très bien que le mal
être que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
est due à une suppression massive de
postes à une complexité sans cesse
accrue de l'exécution des missions je
les dis voire l'impossibilité démission
donc on va être clair à tout ça c'est de
la gesticulation les 26 ou les vingt 20
psychologues qui vont être envoyés au
front si on peut exprimer c'est un terme
à la mode en ce moment mais qui est là
pour le coup qui s'applique parfaitement
parce que effectivement les policiers
sont au front mais c'est passé pas de
psychologues dont ils ont besoin ils ont
besoin du soutien de notre hiérarchie de
l'ensemble de la hiérarchie et surtout
et j'insiste sur ce terme d'une
cohérence en matière de politique
sécuritaire en cette cohérence elle
n'existe pas elle n'est pas lisible si
vous me permettez ce coup de gueule je
crois qu'il faut en arrêter avec ses
discours ses attitudes ses postures qui
en fait ne mène à rien c'est là où je
voulais en venir lorsque je voulais
évoquer une analyse plus micro du
fonctionnement interne de la police
parce que faut être clair un policier où
une policière qui est en souffrance au
sein de son institution a beaucoup
rencontrent beaucoup de difficultés pour
s'exprimer et pour verbaliser son mal
être ça tient à une ambiance générale de
fonctionnement des services on a du mal
à exprimer son mal-être ces
interrogations vous passez vite pour le
si vous me permettez l'expression pour
le cas soc de service qui n'est pas bien
dans ses baskets et qui donc va embêter
ses petits camarades à l'exercice
émissions qui sont déjà pas par ailleurs
suffisamment complexe donc on est face à
une quadrature du cercle ce pouvoir
comme beaucoup d'autres avant lui c'est
toujours désintéressés de l'efficacité
réelle des systèmes des programmes
sécuritaire ce qui ne va pas c'est que
l'on ne maîtrise plus rien vous le voyez
bien pas plus tard que ce matin on a
assisté à un reportage qui a eu lieu à
brest brest brest c'est pas chicago
s'est pas marseille d'accord et on se
rend compte que 13 dégénéré 30 par donc
30 dégénéré dans une cité font régner la
terreur 30 type arrive à mettre un
quartier en coupe réglée sans que ni la
police et encore moins la justice ne
trouvait à remédier à cette situation il
ya un vrai problème du sens donné à
l'action pas simplement policière
d'ailleurs à l'action judiciaire on le
sait bien c'est l'exécution des peines
qui pose problème est il normal que 30
délinquants mettre en coupe réglée des
quartiers et c'est pâques à brest à
marseille c'est pareil contrairement aux
déclarations je dirais jupitérienne d'un
préfet délégué à la sécurité on ne
maîtrise rien on va être très clair et
ce n'est pas en envoyant des crs dans
des quartiers qu'on a totalement perdu
qu'on va régler des problématiques de
trafic de drogue une dernière question
mais très rapidement alors quelles
solutions concrètes voilà pensez vous
qu'il faudrait apporter à cette réponse
urgente mettre des réponses concrètes y
en aurait plusieurs se serait déjà de
mettre les bonnes personnes aux bons
postes je suis désolé on nous ment
quelqu'un comme eric dupond-moretti
ministère de la justice c'est pas
l'individu en soi qui pose problème
c'est la vision qu'il a lui-même de
l'institution judiciaire cet homme sait
très bien où sont les priorités mais
comme gérald darmanin ils savent tous on
n'a pas à faire des naïfs vous savez il
faudrait tout simplement avoir une vraie
politique de politique d'incarcération
d'un de redonner du sens à l'exécution
des peines tout simplement du sens à la
loi et aux pouvoirs régaliens
aujourd'hui nous en sommes très loin
tout est manuel mac on découvre le
problème de la sécurité dans ce pays
cinq ans après sa prise de pouvoir
c'est même pas un procès d'intention que
je ferai à ce président les deux autres
qui devront précédé ont fait exactement
la même chose ils n'ont tenu que nous
discutons que des postures remercie
beaucoup jean-pierre colombiès d'avoir
répondu à mervans je rappelle que vous
êtes porte-parole de l'union des
policiers nationaux indépendants